vaselina benzia Russia's ambassador to
the United Nations on the first working
day of his country's presidency of the
U.N security Council since 1946 the
presidency has rotated among the 15
members April is Russia's turn but the
council is the body in the International
System that governs Global Peace and
security and there's been uproar
particularly in Western countries that
Russia which invaded its neighbor and
whose president faces an arrest warrant
from the international criminal court
now holds the prominent role we expect
that they will behave professionally
but we also expect that they will use
their seat to spread disinformation and
to promote their own agenda as it
relates to Ukraine this was the Russian
ambassador's response some countries are
pretending they can decide at their own
will Who
they want or do not want to be in the
chair of the presidency of the security
Council
as long as the current world order
with the UN and the security Council
stance there will be no change in the
rules of procedure those rules though do
give the president the option to recuse
themselves during the discussion of
items they're directly involved in and
to temporarily hand the presidency to
the next country in alphabetical order
so if the issue of Ukraine comes up this
month
there's the provision for you then to
hand the presidency for that subject
over to Switzerland no yes that's no why
not if if you put the question this way
then I think a few other countries that
are on the security Council should also
uh withdraw from that discussion the
program that Russia has prepared for the
security Council this month is
relatively light but the controversy is
likely to grow towards the end of the
month when the Russian foreign minister
Sergey lavrov comes to New York to chair
the council James Bays Al Jazeera at the
United Nations